Mike McCarty here the game spot news
update the fans have spoken and it looks
like red dead redemption no longer has
the number one spot for Xbox one
backwards compatibility following
Microsoft's e3 announcement of backwards
compatibility for xbox 360 games on xbox
one the company posted a poll on its
website asking users to vote for which
360 games they want to receive support
rock stars 2010 game red dead redemption
quickly rose to the top of the charts
but black ops 2 has edged it out black
ops 2 isn't the only call of duty game
fans want to play on their xbox 16 call
of duty games made the list of the top
12 including modern warfare 2 and the
original black ops these votes are away
from Microsoft to gauge interest in
which games to make backwards compatible
but the company causes that not all
these games will receive support
currently only a handful of games are
supported but Microsoft is planning to
make more backwards compatible over the
coming months with nearly a hundred by
the end of the year be sure to let us
know what xbox 360 games you want to see
on the Xbox one and for more news stay
tuned to gamespot com
you